welcome to today's session
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
almonds logic community manager
responsible for daily interaction
with thousands of users that are part of
a bioinformatics community
managed by pine biotech in this webinar
we would like to share with you
a few details about a special program we
have
specifically for those interested in a
research project
the program is called omits logic
research
fellowship the research project program
has been designed to help young
researchers
and students take advantage of the bind
for matrix resources for
analysis of complex high throughput
life science data and become versed in
bioinformatics
this program offers you participation in
real
and cutting-edge bioinformatics research
and be part of a renowned bioinformatics
community
the research fellowship is a program for
independent research projects
with community and mentor support for
undergraduate and high school students
we recommend
the three-month option so that you can
have a project ready quickly
for graduate students and researchers
this program will help work on a full
project with a publication in mind
even though we cannot guarantee a
publication we have seen that many of
our research fellows get
to a point where their findings are
thorough and reliable for this objective
the research fellowship has been
designed to help
young researchers and students take
advantage of the bioinformatics
resources
for analysis of complex high throughput
data sets
and complete a research study
if you have already completed the online
training successfully
or have a degree in bioinformatics
or are well versed in bioinformatics we
recommend the three month research
fellowship program
the program will help you develop a
research proposal and complete the
analysis
independently while working with a
mentor and
support from like-minded collaborators
if you are new to bioinformatics and
want to learn
as well as develop a research proposal
and conduct an independent research
project with a potential
poster or publication the six month
research fellowship is for you
in this program you will get training
access to ongoing programs and support
of a community
as you prepare and complete the research
project
the research project
looks at application of bioinformatics
to
big high throughput omix data
i'll just go back here
sorry about this
and the second step is mastering the t
bioinfo cloud based bioformatix platform
understanding of ngs data
expertise with biostatistical tools and
machine learning concepts
for biomedical projects effective use of
functional
annotation and biological interpretation
tools like pathway analysis
cutting edge research with supervised
and unsupervised
multi-omics integration apply
tools to interpret meaningful insights
and start
your bioinformatics ngos projects
the research areas that we focus on are
healthcare
which goes to oncology biology
neuroscience
and biotechnology where application of
metagenomics as well as bioinformatics
in agriculture
computational sciences like data science
and machine learning
now i would want to walk you through
some of the
recent graduates of the research
fellowship program
in this slide we have sri chakraborty
she was a student from iit delhi and was
one of the first
students to complete a research project
which was titled identification and
imaging potential vaccine target for
saskoff
spiked protein based on sarskoff spike
protein
and merscope spiked protein
immunological studies
next we have urja parikh
urja is a student at
nmims and
her project was a neuroscience project
where she worked on the identification
of stem cell marker genes
and quiescent and proliferative states
of gbm by comparing rna-seq data from
gbm
tumor samples and controlled brain
samples and neural stem cells
may be joining us today so are you here
today
we would like to hear more from you uh
at the end of the program
hi beeps yes i'm here okay great uh so
uja we would like to hear
a few more words from you uh right at
the end
so thank you so much for uh uh well
joining today thank you thank you so
much for inviting me
thank you yeah so moving on uh we have
de lara uh who joined us from the
bachelor university in turkey
and she did a very interesting project
where she studied the radiation threat
to humans in space
by taking a probiotic approach to this
treatment
and she also joined
with her fellow uh semi
dolinar and simai did a project
on lymphocytic leukemia and all of these
project examples are also available on
our website and
ela if you can kindly share the link in
the chat box please
thank you so moving on
these are just a few project examples
and also the
resources and some of the reviews by
our recent research fellows
this project was by dr anita ganash
and dr emika both of them collaborated
on this project and have recently
completed this program with us
so for today's session we have uh
two participants two research fellows
who would
uh want to present to all of us present
here today
we have andres talking about alzheimer's
as well as rudivi so i would like to
invite
rudy to go ahead and share her slides
uh rudby hi bhipsa
i'll just share my screen sure yes i'll
stop my shirt please go ahead
is it visible yes rudy we can see your
slides
yeah so before starting my slides hi
i'm ruthvi and i'm currently serving as
the campus ambassador of find biotech
and i'm also serving as the president of
this canonics club that is an initiative
taken by pine biotech
i really wish to study in depth and take
my
this topic into my project that is
neural circuits how
they compute and the mechanisms
underlying
in alzheimer's disease so to begin with
i
like to introduce you all to what neural
circuits
actually are we all know that there are
some theses that support that single
neurons compute
solely and individually but when
group of neurons come together with that
synaptic transmissions
and synaptic ends attached to each other
they form a network and a connectivity
group
together this is known as a neural
circuit the neural circuits work by a
feedback
loop mechanism now a feedback loop
mechanism is followed in the brain
or else in the nervous system which
means that a feedback loop
is a process in which the outputs of the
nervous system
are circled back and used as inputs of
the nervous system
neurons who form neural circuits
exhibits three kind of characteristics
the first one is neurons cannot function
in isolation
second one is neurons are grouped
according to function
that is similar kinds of neurons perform
same functions
are grouped similarly third one is
synaptic connections define the circuit
the type of synaptic connections define
the circuit
by that i mean the longer synaptic
connections
form larger neural circuits and the
shorter ones
form a normal or diminishable neural
circuits
there are two types of connections
further on first is very simpler and we
all know about that
is exon and dendrite connection and the
second one is the neuromuscular
junctions
they the specifically neuron muscular
junctions
helps and allows the motor neuron to
transmit a signal
to the muscle fiber which further on
causes muscle contraction
on my right side of the slide i hope you
can see my cursor
i have put a picture of a small part of
neural circuits and how a neurons
interact with each other
the points highlighted shows the firing
and the synaptic trans
synaptic ends by which the neurons are
connected to other neurons
moving on the neuron talking about
specifically the neural circuit
in this slides i would like to talk
specifically about the cortical circuits
and the hippocampal circuits
talking about the cortex neocortex is a
part of cerebral cortex
which is mainly associated with
intelligence and attention
also neocortex has a specialized type of
cells
that is known as pyramidal neurons these
are triangular shaped bodies
and their main function of them is to
transform synaptic inputs into a
patterned
output of action potential talking about
neocortex
it has six layers namely molecular
plexiform layer
external and internal granular layer
external and internal parameter layer
and the
last one that is multiple multiforme
fusiform levels
so together neocortical neurons play a
main role
in neural circuitry because they are
associated with attention
and intelligence moving on how a neuron
works and process
information in the whole circuit this
whole phenomena works on
an earth's equation the formula i have
stated right over here
in which a nurse equation and the
phenomena it allows to follow
make sure that ions move on the either
side of the membrane
equally in such a way that they can
balance out the diffusion of the iron
and hence the electric forces are also
balanced
talking about neuronal signaling
neuronal signaling helps us
in many ways also a neural circuit
because it
explains how one type of electrical
signal
that is the action potential allows
information
to travel along the length of a nerve
cell and how other types of signals
that is both electrical and chemical are
generated
at synaptic connections neural signaling
further also helps us in tracking the
flow of information
the two graded are the two types of
potential channels
that is graded potentials and action
potentials help in neuronal signaling
talking about graded potentials they
travel over short distances
and the main mechanism activating the
graded potential is mechanical gated
channels
mechanically gated channels is
especially present in sensory neurons
talking about action potential these are
activated by
voltage-gated channels that is the
sodium potassium channels
moving on properties every neural
circuit have
these four basic properties namely
feedback
that i already explained that every
output of the neural system
is taken as an input of the other neuron
system
talking about degeneracy by degeneracy
the neural circuits that exact examine
degeneration
allows the same outcome
or the same function to be served by a
group of different neurons
talking about competition the neurons or
the exons which have small scale output
and do not function that efficiently are
eliminated in the development of nervous
system
and talking about modularity it permits
an organism
to process a new output without
involving
a whole of the novel circuit from the
scratch
so my two questions i would like to put
over here is
what is the nature of attention and how
does it enable the initial encoding of
the memory
throughout the neural circuitry involved
in memory storage
now we all know that when we pay
attention there are certain kind of
memory cells
and grid cells that are attached that
are present in our brain
that form a specific pattern when we pay
attention to something
so what is the nature of this attention
and how this
encoding of the memory takes place the
second
question is how does brain neural
circuits
generate rapid and unexpected actions
like what is the underlying mechanism
beneath
this specifically about
alzheimer's and memory circuitry there
have been many research and papers
stating that
at the early onset of alzheimer's the
neural circuits are destroyed
and these neural circuits are destroyed
because of the many reasons we'll
discuss ahead
this slide particularly shows the four
types of different views of the brain
neural circuits
the first one that is diagram number a
is the lateral medial view
showing the hippocampus and para
hippocampus gyrus region
that is in the temporal rope the second
one is showing
the brain section dissected into the
hippocampus and endorinal cortex
the c1 shows the fornix and papis
circuit
and the lines that is the black line
shows the connection of those circuits
the last one d shows the anatomy of ec
hippocampal network
that is associated again in cognition
and
perception when i was reading
all those research papers talking about
the neural circuitry
i came across this knee stretch paper
that made this 3d constructed image
of the basal forebrain they
they made this utilizing the tools of
bioinformatics
in which they constructed the 3d image
of a cholinergic system in the basal
forebrain now cholinergic system
consists of the cholinergic neurons
that are responsible and play a vital
role in cognition and perception
now this cholinergic neurons release
acetylcholine
which decrease with age means the
production of acetylcholine decreases
with age
however in patients of ad and dementia
the cholinergic cholinergic neurons loss
is one of the most
vital and important characteristics so
the over here you can see in the diagram
ch4
ch5 and cx6 like this all the
cholinergic neurons are
labeled and there are total eight of
them
moving on about the abnormalities of
neural circuitry in alzheimer's diseases
specifically
now we all know that neural circuits are
formed and each of these neural circuits
are further in contact of other neural
circuits
so these all together form a default
mode network
now what is default mode network it is a
group of brain regions
that seem to show lower levels of
activity
when we are engaged in particular type
of tasks like
attention or doing some kind of task but
higher level of activity
when we are awake doing mental exercises
or specifically no kind of
task dmn is usually
spared across the areas like cortical
areas
precunias the posterior cannula cortex
and the cortical region as well
so the question i would like to put
again over here
is what actually hinders the functioning
of
neural circuits in ad so there are
papers that says that the formation of
amyloid plaques disrupts the neural
circuitry
so if it is a myeloid plagues then what
forces these amyloid plaques
to further destroy this neural circuits
what is the underlying mechanism
the second question i would like to put
over here is
can we make a computational model using
bioinformatics tools
to understand the mechanism of disrupted
neural circuits
in alzheimeric patients and compare and
contrast
it with a model of that of a normal
person
and the third type of question is are
any there are there any specific
biomarkers
that are used or that show up at the an
early onset of
alzheimer's disease that can be used to
detect the disruption of neural circuits
at an early stage
so this was the first paper i read that
talked about
impairments of neural circuit function
in alzheimer's disease
the paper had beautifully focused the
types of problems each and every neural
circuits goes through
at the early onset of alzheimer's so the
main focus is of this paper was
it showed that the impairment of
cortical neurons by amyloid plaques was
one of the main prime characteristics
second hippocampal hyperactivity because
when amyloid plague formation
increased hippocampal hyperactivity also
increased
due to this the local circuit function
has deteriorated and hence
brain couldn't function properly tending
to forgetfulness to that particular
person
fourth was ab induced that is a myeloid
plaque induced breakdown of
long-range synaptic brain circuits due
to this the long-range synaptic
connections of the neurons were
destroyed and hence
the neural circuits further cannot
compute properly
the fifth part that we'll discuss at the
end of this slide was about
the therapeutic mechanisms that are used
using machine learning and debris
stimulation
to treat alzheimer's disease and how far
have they been worked
the second type of paper that i read was
comparing the
mechanisms of alzheimer's disease in
mice
as well as human so the prime focus of
this whole
paper was the hippocampal hyperactivity
some say it is a cause and some say it
is a consequence
so researchers and scientists are still
yet to find a
answer to this question that is
hippocampal hyperactivity a cause or a
consequence
because we all know that hippocampus is
a region that plays an important role in
learning memory
and cognition so it has been stated that
in
early stages of a d when connections
between
uh i mean connectivity between
hypocampus
and other brain areas have been
destroyed
the neural circuit function also
destroys
so this was the main idea of this paper
talking about the possible therapeutic
mechanisms of
deep brain stimulation so scientists and
researchers since the past
ticket have been trying to resolve and
have been trying to
attain the therapeutic mechanisms for
treating alzheimer's
so they thought that involving the
neural circuitry and repairing the
damage done to neural circuitry could be
one of the possible therapeutic
mechanisms
for this so the first one was involving
dbs
in the synaptic laws so they tried to
insert this data the brain stimulating
system into the post commercial fornix
that
is the pap use and the black circuit
that i showed earlier
so due to this they can help prevent
neuronal loss in that particular area of
the brain
second dbs in the neural circuits can
also
and is believed to induce neurogenesis
so this could help us to
produce more neurons rather than having
the loss of the neurons which is the
typical
characteristics of alzheimeric patients
third dbs in memory circuits also
enhances the glucose metabolism levels
and researchers have found out that in
early onset of aid the glucose levels in
temporal and posterior cingulate area
have been reduced so using this tbs
cerebral glucose metabolism levels can
also be
increased the fourth one they also drive
that is the deep brain simulating
systems
also drive interaction between media and
cortical limbic circuits
hence restoring the connectivity in the
hippocampal regions
and the fifth that is the last one dbs
also
reduce the formation of amyloid beta
plaques
that help restore the kind of neurons
lost
or the cholinergic neurons lost which
would help to reduce the rate of
progression of the alzheimer's disease
so i would like to conclude my
presentation over here
thank you um
thank you so much for sharing it if you
can keep your screen shared
and i would like to ask anybody from the
audience if they have any questions for
rugby
if you have any questions you can please
go ahead and post those questions either
in the chat box
or even unmute yourself and ask the
questions
so i had a question um
so rudeby have you found any data sets
that could help you
study this beyond literature review
hi elia actually uh finding the data
sets part was where i was actually stuck
but what i could what i was able to find
out was that
all the scientists who did this work on
neural circuits
gave approach from a transcriptomics
point of view
and the sources they used of
bioinformatics particularly was
machine learning algorithms
thank you
[Music]
there is a question from mia her
question is does dbs have
application in ms
does tb have an application in ms to be
more specific scientists have been still
on alzheimer's disease for treating
alzheimer's disease with dbs but if they
get
some success in alzheimer's disease then
probably they can
use dbs for ms patients and parkinson's
patients
as well but yet the mechanism still can
differ from patient to patient
i hope i answered your question yeah mia
says thank you
thank you so much thank you if you have
any more questions then
we can again hear those questions later
on you can keep posting them
in the chat box and now i would want to
invite andres uh andres are you here
hi andres uh okay yeah we can see you
yes hi so andres is presenting next
uh andres please go ahead uh yeah so
hello i hope that you are all having a
great time
so my name is andres and i'm a high
school student from mexico city
and i am currently doing the mixologic
bioinformatics research fellowship
i am interested in studying how long
coding rna mediated or inflammation in
alzheimer's disease
so first what is alzheimer's disease
so alzheimer's disease is an
irreversible progressive brain disorder
characterized by memory loss and
cognitive deficits and it is also the
most
the most common cause of dementia and i
think that is the sixth leading cause of
that in the
us so what are the pathological
harmonics of alzheimer's disease so
uh alzheimer's alzheimer's disease
characterized by the accumulation of
extracellular
beta-amyloid uh deposits uh which later
lead to the development of senile
plaques
and this has been shown to disrupt uh
the communication between cells
thus causing the activation of immune
cells and these immune cells
then trigger an inflammatory response uh
the other pathological hallmark of
alzheimer's disease
uh is a hybrid phosphorylation of tau
protein
which can lead to the development of
intracellular neurofibrillary tangles or
nfts
uh and these tangles uh then well they
lead to the blockage
of the energies transport system which
can lead to
uh microtubule structures are collapsing
and these uh structures
they basically uh constitute uh
like not the network but uh the way
through which uh
nutrients neurons get nutrients and so
as they collapse
uh this can result in neuronal death
uh and so um both uh
neurofibrillary tangles and amyloid
accumulation
are uh widely recognized as a core
pathologies of
ab and until like 10 years ago it hadn't
been
uh shown how how they
were linked or how they related to one
another uh
but scientists started to realize that
neuro inflammation so an inflammatory
response
uh was very uh
uh like it was uh there was a huge
increase in near inflammation in the
brain
uh in patients that exhibited uh
cognitive deficits uh caused by
alzheimer's disease
and so uh like scientists currently
believe that
uh near inflammation could provide the
link between the development of uh
xenoplakes and uh the development of
neurofibrillary tangles
and so uh scientists believe that this
inflammatory response uh
could constitute the third core
pathology of alzheimer's disease
uh and so like what they believe is that
the accumulation of amyloid beta
uh leads to the activation of this
inflammatory response which then
exacerbates the development of
neurofibrillary tangles
which later leads to neuronal death thus
causing uh
cognitive deficits in the development of
clinical dementia
and so now i will talk a little bit
about these
inflammatory response so
the inflammatory response in alzheimer's
disease is mediated by microbial
microglial cells
which are actually immune cells and they
are the brain's resident macrophages
and these cells uh their function is to
remove uh
damaged nerves and debris in the central
nervous system
uh and as i mentioned previously um
it has been shown that the accumulation
of amyloid beta deposits which later
lead to the development of senile flakes
leads to an increase in the activity of
microglial cells
and so when microglial cells become
activated they can
adopt either one of two states
they can adopt the m1 phenotype which
produces a pro-inflammatory response
or they can be produced they can adopt
the m2 phenotype which produces an
anti-inflammatory response
uh and so
most patients uh that exceeded uh
well that developed alzheimer's uh they
have been shown to
uh develop neuroinflammation and so this
chronically active microclia
as i mentioned previously as they adopt
the pre-inflammatory phenotype
they exacerbate both amyloid and type
pathologies
and uh well they continue to they
produce this inflammatory response uh
by excreting uh cytokines and rose so
reactive oxygen species
and well these of course uh can damage
neurons and thus uh
increase uh well it can lead to neuronal
death and thus
uh resulting cognitive deficits
um and because of these uh
well activated microglia they correlate
with alzheimer's disease
um and uh well as i mentioned they can
adopt either one of these two phenotypes
for the m1 pinot nine
or the m2 phenotype but it has been
shown that it isn't uh
as polarized as this image so it is more
of a spectrum
and so uh i am interested in doing a
transcriptomic analysis
uh as to how the
like to explain the variability uh
between
microglial cells according to the
phenotype that they exceeded
and to see what releases sporalize as
polarized as this image we see
really more of the spectrum and then to
be able to identify
whether uh the activation of
uh pro-inflammatory microglia uh
can in fact really uh will lead to the
further development of
cognitive deficits in clinical demands
and so this leads to my scientific
question uh
well my research proposal uh so
understanding the transcriptomic
differences that underlie the variety of
phenotypes along the m1 m2 spectrum
could allow us to identify therapeutic
targets that mediate microbial
activation states and their inflammation
in alzheimer's disease
uh and so i made these uh three
different questions so
what genes are expressed at a higher
level in m1 microglial cells
what genes are expressed at a higher
level in m2 microglial cells
and how the gene expression profiles of
the phenotypes along the m1m2 spectrum
differ from each other
then could certain transcriptomic
differences be used as novel biomarkers
to diagnose alzheimer's disease
and or map the progression of the
disease and as i mentioned at the
beginning of my presentation i am
interested in long non-coding rnase
so long non-coding rnase well non-coding
rnas are a type of rna
that is transcribed from the genome but
doesn't undergoes translation
meaning that it isn't used to synthesize
a protein
and long non-coding rnas have been shown
to regulate gene expression
as they modulate transcription of
transcriptional and post-transcriptional
processes
[Music]
and they have also been
scientists have found that long
non-coding rnas are averagely expressed
in both
inflammatory diseases and
neurodegenerative diseases
and i haven't really seen uh any
research
a paper that talks about long non-coding
rna
in microglia without focus to
alzheimer's disease
as and so i'm interested in studying uh
how does the expression of luminance
coding rna is different between
uh microglia that adopt either the
pro-inflammatory
phenotype or the anti-inflammatory kind
so i haven't
done any extensive research i would say
uh i've only done some exploratory data
analysis and i found
these data said that data set in ncbi
uh which was uh titled
uh transcriptomic profiling of microglia
and astrocytes uh throughout aging
and so what scientists did with this
study they had uh
three mice and they collected uh two
types of cell for each mice so they
collected both astrocytes and microglia
uh and then well they had to experiment
the
two groups they either had wild-type
mice or
alzheimer's disease mobile mice uh these
mice were the
uh i think they're called uh yes they're
called eight pps one mice
and uh these mice are very used for
alzheimer's research
uh as they exhibit a remarkable
elevation of amino peda deposits
and so uh i thought that these uh
dataset would be very useful for what i
want to study
because it will allow me to see how
higher levels of amyloid beta deposits
influence the expression of microglial
cells
and to see uh whether
these higher levels of amyloid beta does
in fact correlate to
the expression of genes associated with
uh inflammation and inflammatory
responses
uh however i also know well uh ilia
noticed really uh
that uh they used polya rna sequencing
and so
there will be an over an over
representation of uh
coding regions and coding mrnas uh
in their uh like their data set and so
this
dataset isn't really useful for um
for studying uh long-run coding rnas
and while i perform these uh pca
analyses in here
uh and of course i mean this graph
doesn't really tell you anything except
that
uh microglia and astrocytes have really
uh
different uh expression profiles but
like you would expect that regardless of
whether they are from wild type mice or
av
mice simply because they are like a
different type of cell
and so what i did next was to uh oh wait
i think there are some questions
uh answer the questions once you finish
the presentation you can address them
okay yeah just that i can see the chat
so i think i'll have to
stop showing and then see because i can
see it right now
okay i'll read it for you no problem
okay
uh and so what i did was to um i
performed the
a pca but dividing the
well in for this presentation for the
purposes of my presentation here
i only uh show the microglial cells
because that's what i'm interested in
studying
so i performed an individual pca
analysis only with the microglia
so that we could get a better
understanding of how
uh of how there is a variability within
the microglial cells and within the
expression problems of these cells
and so as you can see of course this
isn't also really helpful because there
are only i think there were
12 uh samples
and although you can you see like some
clustering here uh there really isn't a
great difference between the wild type
microli and the av microglia
but then i also labeled it according to
the
to the h of the mice of the samples and
i found it really interesting to see
that you could actually see
well except for the 12 months old
microglia that they are
uh really uh like close to each other so
here you guys you can see the
two months old microglia here you can
see the nine months old microglia
here you can see the formula and so here
you can see that is six months old
so i thought that was interesting and
well for the
like next i'm only beginning with my
research project of course
uh and i am really interested in doing a
factor regression analysis
in which i can study how the expression
of
the expression uh profile of these cells
before uh according to each of the
different variables
so of course the cell type uh the age of
the mice
and also uh of course whether they are a
wildlife mice or a
alzheimer's disease model mice uh
but i also will need to find a data set
that uh accounts for the for
uh well that also takes longer encoding
rna into consideration
uh but also a dataset that studies
microglial cells in both physiological
and pathological conditions
so i guess that this first data set that
i found uh is uh
really useful but because if they used a
polya rna sequencing it
isn't that helpful for me and also i
think that they
had relatively few samples uh especially
taking into account how many variables
they were
they they had uh and so
that's pretty much it thanks a lot
um thank you andres uh so we will ask if
anybody
has any questions uh elia do you have
any question for andres
no i'll just briefly comment i think
that this is a
a nice presentation not only of the
research question
but also some data sets that you have
found
and you're starting to see some trends
and translating those into specific
analysis plans so i think that's really
uh the objective of this program
and so it's exciting to see what you
have found up until now
and hopefully we'll see more progress
soon
so thank you for that and you know just
looking at the questions i noticed that
a lot of the questions were actually not
related to the project topic
itself but i do want to ask that if
anyone who is interested in alzheimer's
disease and neuroscience research and
things like that
if you have any other types of questions
for undress please post them in the chat
or you can review yourselves
so thank you uh so much andres yes abdul
you have a question yes please go ahead
uh okay abdul does not have a mind but
abdul you can post your question in the
chat box
andres can answer your question
and maybe in the meantime as people are
asking about the program itself
and how to register and things like that
we will address those questions towards
the end of the
presentation today so let's just try and
figure out if we can have
the discussion about alzheimer's and the
projects that have been presented
right okay
okay so andres uh i mean i have already
looked at your pca plots
and because you compare some of the uh
clinical phenotypes of the samples with
the
results of these pca plots so
besides i think uh i think uh how many
clinical phenotypes that you have found
according to if i'm looking at
just pattern without just you forget
about
uh the clinical phenomena i mean exactly
the clinical
uh clinical phenotype that you have
representing here
can you tell me how many other clinical
phenotypes that you have found in this
particular data
uh i mean in terms of like clinical what
do you mean with clinical phenotypes
exactly
clinical characteristics of the i mean
these samples
like they have already you represent
these are bile type
uh wild type and uh other plants right
i mean they used two types of ice so
they had the wild type myosin the
a the alzheimer's disease uh mice
and also like the other variable was the
age of the mice as i
showed uh and also the type of
cell that they were studying so whether
it was a microglial cell or an
astrocytes
uh but in terms of the actual phenotype
so they
uh yeah as you said the clinical
phenotype i don't think that they
accounted for that in the
data set at least i don't see okay so
even based on the age group i mean uh
you have like divide
already divided uh you have taken there
and already
the time they have provided i think they
can be further like
you can actually make groups like you
know
junk then you can uh actually uh
then adults and then older one i mean
you can even
make sub groups like two and four month
as
uh jungle group and then you can
actually meet an intermediate uh
adult group that is i think four months
then you can actually
like 12 months it's very late i mean
it's like a one year right
so that could be older group so you can
actually divide these
uh clinical subtypes into the another
group
it doesn't matter like already they have
if provided like
number of the groups like age group
could be varied
from one month to 12 month or how many i
mean you can
further subdivide it and make uh other
groups
as well okay
so then i think then you can compare
exactly
or which microglial astros or the
astrocytes actually
represented by with this data can be
represented
okay yeah you can i'm sorry
yeah you can go ahead i mean uh no
like i really haven't uh studied any of
that in terms of like
categorizing my data according to as you
mentioned this clinical phenotype
uh but uh as i mentioned i found it uh
really interesting uh that you could
actually see in the pca
that i mean of course uh that could even
be like over
interpretation uh but the fact that
uh and also because they had really few
uh samples
but the fact that the demise that uh had
the same age
they were relatively closing the pca
uh so yeah i mean i think that like by
studying the gene expression and how it
varies uh
in an age uh dependent manner
it would be interesting to study like
how it varies
and to be able to categorize the
phenotype according uh
like so in the 80 mice uh
according to how the disease starts to
progress to progress
okay so because i believe especially if
we talking about alzheimer's
it would be more uh prone to the older
people right
so that's why i'm saying that first we
should i mean divide
these groups into like different age
groups not just the age group just
making like
one as you can include some particular
time
period as younger group then you can
actually as adult group then older group
and then you can actually look into
exactly
how i mean how microglial are actually
can be
uh i mean their pattern is different in
comparison to the different age groups
and then you can find out the diff
specific transcriptomic signatures
and i would add to that that there's
actually
two distinct types of alzheimer's
disease one is for older people
or called all like you know late onset
alzheimer's
and another one is for early onset
alzheimer's i think they just represent
two different diseases really
yes uh and actually uh what you just
mentioned
is really interesting because there had
been this uh case in colombia i think it
was
uh with this family they always had this
mutation
which they started to develop
alzheimer's disease when they were like
40 so it was really early onset
and there was this woman uh who everyone
expected that she would develop
alzheimer's because they had these uh
really really aggressive uh uh
sort of mutation that led to the
development of early onset alzheimer's
disease
uh and so when she was 70 she still
hadn't developed any cognitive deficits
or any signs of dementia
and so uh when she died she donated her
brain and they started to
study it and they realized that she had
like this
like crazy amount of amyloid beta
deposits like
horrible amount of uh like it was full
of amino acid beta but she
didn't have any uh like signs of
a neuronal death which has led
scientists also to believe that
uh maybe there is an intrinsic
resistance against
amyloid beta and so uh certain patients
will
produce an inflammatory uh response
uh due to these these deposits uh but
then
uh others will have like a higher
resistance per se
well not like not exactly but this is
just like a hypothesis
which might lead to some patients uh
like not developing
uh clinical dementias early and so
that's also really interesting i think
they
publish an article about this in the new
york times
okay so thank you i think it looks an
interesting problem
in fact within uh just with this com
only running when we are running a pca
so it representing some pattern so we
can actually
then go beyond to understand and
identify some specific
transcriptomic signatures and then we
can look into whether those
uh specific transcriptomic signature
able to discriminate these groups of the
samples
hello testing testing one two
okay so i think thank you andres
uh i think uh
and i hope that's did you have any
questions yeah
um he said you can also compare them
outside
to the human age group by comparing the
physiological development so yeah i
believe that that would be
uh really interesting to do but i would
of course first uh have to find a
a dataset with this information and of
course with humanity is much more
complicated because
most of the time the tissues that you
have available are from postmortem
well like after the patient is so
postmortem samples
and so of course it will be really
interesting to study but at least from
what i found it's
somehow much more difficult to found uh
to find these data sets but i will look
for them
hello oh yes
oh you can hear me fantastic my question
um see i i didn't come into this course
of regarding my university you know
study now i just came from interest and
just put a personal development i wanted
to learn more about bioinformatics
that's my area of
interest as a career i would like to
express however
i have a paper to do coming up and it's
about alzheimer's
what a coincidence and i wanted maybe to
reach out to possible
uh fellow members within this call if i
could maybe
you know discuss further about the
disease itself and get your insight
and hopefully and gather some notes to
develop me more about of the um topic
itself if that's okay
yeah i abdul yeah i think that's a great
idea and
we're kind of going to discuss uh
resource that we have developed
which might be beneficial for you so
just wait for
some more time and we'll be discussing
that and
also the possible things that we can do
together
great fantastic thanks so much thank you
so much abdul and thank you so much
andres
uh it was really a great presentation
now i would like to invite elia to
explain to you how
uh the research fellowship program works
and the project process elia
over to you yes thank you and
i will just briefly explain because i
think a lot of people have
this common interest in having a project
that could be developed
and a lot of people struggle with how to
actually develop a project
that is interesting and impactful and
what are the specific steps involved
in such a process so as you have seen
today we've seen rubies and andre's
presentations
both of them started from an in-depth
overview
of different types of articles in the
public domain so
one of the common things that you will
find the different types of literature
that you will find
related to a particular topic could be
review articles
they could be primary research articles
they could be different types of
databases
and kind of accumulation of different
types of resources that people review
so in that process i think that it's
important to
sample both types or all three types
and as you do that you will notice that
in many areas and specifically in an
area like alzheimer's disease that is
not
clear-cut there is a lot of open
questions you're likely
to identify what are the topics
that have significant gaps or maybe
unanswered questions and even
controversial debate so a good example
in alzheimer's disease is the
accumulation of amyloid plaques
where people think that maybe that's the
cause
other people think that that's the
result no one
knows really whether just addressing
that issue you're treating the symptom
or the actual disease
another good example is in general
whether mutations
or gene expression patterns or
epigenetic variation
is really what is the primary source of
different types of disease developments
so there are many open questions in
alzheimer's disease and
neurodegenerative diseases in general
and once you've identified those then
you go through the process of defining
your question or hypothesis and that's
an important part because
when you uh just initially kind of have
a question it's likely to be
non-specific so it's likely to see
people that say well i want to study
the development of alzheimer's disease
or i want to study the treatment of
alzheimer's disease
and as we've seen in today's
presentations those
questions are too general to answer they
are being
answered by thousands of different
projects and thousands of different more
specific
questions that need answering to move
forward
in those kinds of directions so that
process
is very important and as we think about
that process of literature review
i want to give you a couple of examples
of the specific steps that you will
likely go through
as you develop your project into a
research
especially using bioinformatics or using
data so
as i mentioned the first step is framing
the problem and that's done through
literature review
like we just saw the second part is
many questions cannot be answered
because
data is not available and to collect the
data
into identifying a data set that clearly
elucidates that specific problem that
you're trying to focus on
is a process of reviewing a lot of
available data sets so
for example in the case of root v she
mentioned that she hasn't found the data
she just knows what type of data she
would be looking for which is
transcriptomic data
in the case of andres he mentioned that
he found
several different data sets those
different data sets contain different
samples different groups of samples
different clinical phenotypes
some of them come from cell cultures
some of them come from
mouse model some of them come from real
patients
they probably were generated using
different sequencing library preparation
techniques
maybe different sequencers so you have
to go through those details to identify
a data set that you will use and
sometimes people decide to combine
different data sets
now after my presentation i will pass it
on to
dr mohit mizunder who will speak about
some
resources that you can leverage to find
data sets
and review what is available but after
you've identified
that data probably needs to be processed
and by processing
i mean a number of different things it
could mean that the data is in raw
data format that needs to be structured
it could mean that the data has to be
normalized or scaled
it could mean that the data has to be
changed from exam
for example from some kind of an array
id for your gene ids to maybe ensemble
id or common gene id so you have to
transform that data and that's an
important part of data preparation
and after you've prepared the data you
have to explore it so what today we saw
from andres presentation he was showing
pca analysis
he was talking about how he would like
to use his
insights from pca to develop a
factor regression analysis model and so
that process of exploring the data means
several different things that means that
we're looking for patterns like outliers
so if i have some technical issues with
samples
i might not necessarily want to use them
in
my analysis downstream maybe
you are seeing bigger separation between
groups by tissue type and that might
mean that you want to then specifically
focus on
one of the tissue types and not take
both it could mean that you're not
seeing a pattern at all in the data that
you found
and maybe that means you need to look
for a different project or maybe a
different type of data
so maybe it's not gene expression maybe
it's long non-coding rnas
maybe it's not expression at all maybe
it's mutation variance
or maybe it's neither one of those maybe
it's the regulation part
maybe methylation of dna or maybe it's
the histone modification right
so there's many different questions that
you can come up with
as you explore the data and then finally
you go through
an in-depth analysis that means you've
chosen a statistical model or maybe a
machine learning model
to identify some patterns and then those
patterns need to be
explained need to be biologically
explained and so when
we go through the process of in-depth
analysis
that combines the analysis using
statistical and bioinformatics tools
but also it combines biological mapping
and interpretation so how do you map
the differentially expressed genes onto
pathways
how do you understand the meaning of
gene
function through gene ontology and
through pathway analysis
how do you also fit it in to how people
interpret disease so what today we saw
from root v
are these signaling networks so
signaling networks
is an attempt to piece together the
puzzle
individual pieces that we might observe
in different tissues
in different cell types into these
signaling
into these signaling um uh kind of uh
you know sequences right so what goes
from what and how does that affect the
overall
phenotype that we can interpret for
example ability to focus or ability to
remember right
those are the phenotypes that we're
willing to investigate
um and and then finally as you saw today
presentation is a big part of this
process
so what we try to do in the
bioinformatics research fellowship
is to try to help the participants the
fellows
develop their projects to a point where
the presentation is clear
and it provides sufficient information
for those that come from the outside to
be able to understand what the problem
is
to understand what data was used what is
the analysis that's being done
and how that analysis leads to these
other steps of interpretation and
biological insight
and a big part of that is smooth
presentation where
you eliminate unnecessary information
you focus on the information that is
impactful and needed
and finally you're able to speak about
it and answer questions and so that was
really the purpose of today's
presentation is to give them that
opportunity
and we hold these kinds of sessions
regularly on different topics
so to conclude i would like to pass my
screen to dr mohit mazumder who will
speak about
some resources that we have identified
to help you
study further alzheimer's disease
i'll pass it on to you
thank you india
so hello everyone uh for those who are
joining for the first time my name is
mohit mazumdar and in my current role
i'm collaborating and
working with academia and healthcare
industry to provide support for
bioinformatics
bioinformatics research and training
but it's really exciting to be part of
this omixlogic research program as a
program mentor
and to be able to work on translational
research with a diverse group of
students
with different expertise so my phd work
was focused on developing a noble
methods to identify and predict calcium
binding sites and study binding affinity
towards calcium
but as a project mentor i can help you
with analysis steps that elia just
showed
and the understanding of the sequence
data
and the patterns within that data and
further investigate into
the 3d three-dimensional space by using
structural biology tools and
computational modeling of biological
systems
and uh looking at the dynamics so
uh alzheimer's disease is a complex
neurodegenerative disease
caused by several genetic and epigenetic
factors
that are driven by genetic variations
changes in
gene expression transcriptomics as well
as gene environmental interactions
that could be involved in disease onset
so in this modern era wet lab
experiments are producing
vast quantity of data that scientific
discoveries are relying on
so that that's what we have learned so
far that these experiments are
generating thousands of data sets
that are readily available for
biomedical and biotechnology studies
but to get answers this flow of data has
to be analyzed
effectively right so gene expression
patterns
in association with clinical data can
help identify
molecular biomarkers or diagnostics and
therapeutic uh
select selections right so new
discoveries
include a better understanding of
complex diseases at a sub cellular level
as well as target identification for a
noble drug design
and and also for drug repurposing
so gene expression patterns in
association with clinical data can help
us identify
uh those specific patterns those
specific biomarkers for diagnostics
and for therapy therapy selections and
omix technology like ngs can be used to
explore the roles the relationships and
the actions
of these various types of molecules that
makes up the cell of an organism so many
types of omics data can be generated
using ngs
or what we call as high throughput
sequencing the data can show detailed
information about
genomic variants and the patterns of
genes and
isoform expression as elia was
mentioning
so the recent progress in this high
throughput technology
and this omix era where we are
collecting these
volumes of data and one of the purpose
of
this entire experience of doing omix
logic research
is to be able to explore that data and
to be able to come up with research
questions
by seeing how experts are doing it so
the way we are working
here is we are providing a lot of
examples
so the examples are really helpful for
us to understand that
how a particular study was conducted how
a particular study was designed
and what was what was the outcome of
that study so when you do that
um go through that experience and
through these
um through these uh projects and courses
that we have designed
and they're part of this fellowship
program you will learn about the
possibilities of research that is
available out there the possibilities of
id
of
you know tools and data sets available
out there and with your own idea
with your own thoughts how can you come
up with a noble research
so talking about the resources uh if
you if you want to find resources about
alzheimer's disease and i'm going to
share
a article which explains
all of this in a step-by-step but
this is one of the resources the omics
discovery index that
provides a knowledge discovery framework
across heterogeneous omics data that is
genomics proteomics transcriptomics
metabolomics
so it is an alternative to ncbi data
repositories like co
or sra or embl repositories like
array express so this platform is easy
to use and find data sets on
um alzheimer's diseases another example
is
the single cell gene expression data uh
that could be
interactively accessed here this is fcd
so it's a single cell uh
data database for alzheimer's disease
and
uh you can find data you know across a
brain cell types by identifying
transcriptive
transcriptionally distinct
sub-populations
include those associations with
pathology and characterized by
regulation of you know inflammation
neural survival
so those are like some of the features
that can be thought of
and you know in the context of single
cell uh
transcriptomics data so the resource
that i've been talking about
is about finding omics data to study
alzheimer's disease that we have
accumulated but it's a
combined effort of a team so here
andreas
and also mark ilia dr harpreet
myself all of all of us have contributed
nietzsche
have contributed to uh for this uh
for this article that kind of explains
uh
where to start from and what all is
being going on
and what is being identified at a very
high level
and then you will find a lot of links to
these
articles where these
concepts and discoveries have been
mentioned and also you'll find
case studies where you will find get an
idea of
what this data has been you know what
was the outcome of this kind of analysis
coming from this kind of data so next
there is a section on data repositories
where you will find different
links that you can go to directly visit
and see
and find the data yourself and these
projects
that are available out there kind of
gives you an explanation of
the number of cases number of patients
and the cohort
and all those informations you'll find
within these uh
data sets and then you will find
examples data example data sets that
that are available out there and also
that our interns here andres is working
on
mark is working on and also we have
uh ruth we who is interested to work on
some of these data sets
and we also have puja today along with
us
who just finished a project on
glioblastoma and now have some
interesting research ideas and she's
also completing a
research article or a publication for
the same so
let me share this link with all of you
if it is not already being shared
uh it's in the chat box doctor moment
all right so this is the link and
to answer up those questions so the way
research fellowship works is that we
have a group of people who joined us
after finishing our
training so initial part is the training
and if you are already trained
the second uh step is it's kind of
pretty simple
and why it is simple because the
research itself is quite complex so with
the steps are very simple
so you just have to fill up a form uh
when you join the fellowship program
and then we have meetings with you to
discuss the
possibilities of doing this research
with mentors and
faculty and then we move on to a
stepwise way to
you know conduct that research and to
come up with
outcomes and to be able to present so
this happens with uh independently all
and also uh with a group so
there could be faculties involved in it
there could be researchers there could
be scientists who are part of our
community so it's being a part of this
community and to
explore and to do research in
collaborations
and to with the help of the tools and
also
the tutorials everything is available so
it could be
an easy process to follow and we could
achieve a lot of things in a short
period of time
so uh with this information
um i would like to pass it on to biepcha
first to talk about the registration
process and how to go
how to do the registration and then
maybe uh
uh ooja can add a few words of her
experience and
what she's planning to do thank you
uh thank you so much uh dr mohan
so i wanted to uh first go ahead
and introduce everyone uh to a few of
the project examples which i was talking
about earlier
and as uh all of our research fellows
have shown today and as elia and dr
mohit
has been talking about uh this is
a internship process which is guided by
our mentors so here are a few project
examples
so this first example is the one which i
showed you from srija
where she collaborated for
identification of
a target vaccine for sarskoftu and you
can also see urja's project similarly
we have a lot of projects from our
research fellows as well
as even high school students
who have participated in our program so
if you would like to review the project
i will be sharing the link via chat
and now as dr mohit has been talking
about
the registration for the program and we
also received all of these questions
so if you are looking forward to
register for this program
it is available at fellowship dot
omicslogic.com
you can go to this link and register
and we also have training programs
which help to build you up right from
step one
to reaching to the level where you can
actually go ahead and work on your
own research projects two of such
programs are the omits logic data
science program which we have
just started uh in this week which is
the 12th of january we have had
two introductory sessions and it's still
open for registration especially for
anybody who is more
interested in learning about data
science and application of
machine learning this will be a one
month program
and if you are going to go for an
advanced
license then you can also work on your
own research project
and the second program that we have is
on infectious disease which we are going
to be starting
on january 29th along with
nokuji memorial research center which is
in the university of ghana
and these are the two programs that are
upcoming if you are interested
in joining the programs you can check
this pages out
and as well as reach out to me
because i believe that there are a lot
of links in the chat so in case you miss
anything out we will also be sending you
an email with all of these links
uh that you can access and the other
thing that i wanted to point out
for all of you who are just starting say
a program with us or are looking forward
to start a project we have a lot of
example projects that you can actually
take a look at before
you go ahead and devise a project of
your own
so few of those projects which we have
just introduced is this project on covet
19 that you can take a look at
and this project is typically a free
project that you can
register on edut by info if you already
have an account on edut bioinfo
you can go ahead register for this
project and start
taking this project from here we also
have a project
on the molecular signatures of liver
cancer
so if you are interested in oncology or
if you are
devising a project for oncology or
thinking about it you can take a look at
these projects
as well as we have a project now on
ebola as well
where we study next generation
sequencing
variant detection in the ebola virus
outbreak in west africa
so these are some projects which are
already
ready and prepared
okay all right okay you can actually
reach out to us
uh to let us know that what is the
difficulty you are facing
and and to help you with that we have dr
harpreet on board here
and you can reach out to dr harpreet
that supported pine dot bio for any kind
of
technical questions she guides all of
her research fellows on the project
uh during the whole process and you can
definitely reach out to her and let us
know or you can also let me know if you
have any questions at marketing at
find.bio
and i will be able to help you out by
connecting you with our mentor team who
can answer any specific questions that
you have
so abdul you can email dr harpreet
at support and find on bio oh i
appreciate that
help you yeah okay thank you so much no
thank you because
i want to speak to someone about it and
i'll reach out thank you so much
yeah you're welcome yeah so we always
have a support team
who are here to help you out during this
entire project process so right when you
begin
uh studying these through the various
asynchronous courses that dr mohit has
been showing
and i know that most of you have already
gone through some of the projects
and the courses which are already here
but in case you haven't
once you're going through the
asynchronous materials they first
help you to learn about the logic of
analysis
how to prepare your files where do you
go to look for these different
data files and one resource that i
definitely recommend
everybody to check is our blog we keep
on posting like the alzheimer's project
we have
several other uh resources on biology
and many other uh like alzheimer's right
now
and other resources as well on our blog
so you can take a look at these free
resources and i hope that
that would be helpful to a lot of you so
now
uh i would like to invite urja
to share her experience and talk about
her project
and her future plans with her project so
urja if you would want to go ahead
i'll keep the screen shared on your
project
hi thank you so much yeah okay
okay great
all right so uh like from like whatever
i've read on the chat i think
uh as a student you're starting out or
anyone just starting out with a research
project uh
it's often a confusion as to how to go
about the entire process
so i'll just put it into context with my
own project
so um you need to know like what exactly
are you interested in and since this
uh program is related to alzheimer's
then
um you need to focus on a very specific
area of alzheimer's because it's such a
vast topic and
there's so many aspects to look at but
when i was initially doing my suggests i
was working on the type of brain cancer
called glioblastoma multiforme
and that particular brain cancer is
associated with a very poor prognosis
which is after treatment the patients
can only survive up to 15 months
now uh on a molecular level there are
uh various hypotheses that state the
origin of the tumor
so what i wanted to explore was how the
glioblastoma stem
cells which is a stem cells found in the
tumor
differs from normal neural stem cells
present in the brain
for which i did a rna-seq analysis